[music]
Hey it's me Destin.
Welcome to Smarter Every Day.
So today we're gonna learn about how helicopters work. In fact, we're gonna
put on our thinking hats, today mine looks like this,
and we're gonna do a whole video series.
There's a lot going on there. We're gonna teach you what it is.
Let's get Smarter Every Day.
The reason I am in Tennessee to film this, is because Carl,
I'm pretty sure, is a wizard. I'm not even joking.
Is it OK if I wear this helmet the entire video?
(Carl) Yeah it's awesome.
(Destin) Alright. Carl is gonna operate this helicopter
in ways that I did not know were possible.
The next several videos are all gonna be
about how helicopters work. They're way more complicated than you think, but for the time being
I just want you to see this.
[rotor noise]
(Destin) What kind of sorcery is this?
Can you fly it upside down?
So that's why we're working with Carl today.
Because of that. That's how you mow the yard
in Tennessee huh?
(Carl) Oh yeah.
What you're not feeling is there's like a 10 mile an hour wind and he's.. [laugh]
he's doing this in all the wind. It's pretty crazy.
(Destin) So you realise that
that's some kind of black magic or something right?
(Carl) Oh it defies all physics doesn't it. [laugh]
So you do the numbers on that one.
(Destin) That was messed up dude.
OK so, if you want to know more about how these helicopters work, stay tuned. The next few videos
I'm gonna use high speed video, night time flights, open shutter
photography. Basically a bunch of tricks to show all his tricks.
So, go ahead and subscribe and you'll see these videos
And, will you fly it some more?
(Carl) Absolutely, yeah.
(Destin) Let's just fly it more. Just because it's awesome.
[music]
[ Captions by Andrew Jackson ]
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.